do you think college is overvalued do
you think it's a good investment today
as compared to what was like 50 years
ago I've never thought of it as a bad
investment you've got to find something
you're passionate about because the
worst job in the world is to get up in
the morning and do something you don't
want to do just for money that sucks
great careers are built around passion
that you want to work 24 hours a day
because you really like what you're
doing now if you like engineering that's
the most lucrative career you can have
right now I don't care what discipline
you pick the world doesn't have enough
engineers and the world's competing
against engineering the real value of
college I felt even for engineers is who
you meet you're going to forget
everything they teach you five years
later but you're going to know a lot of
people that are going to help you in
your path and I think that's the value
so if you can afford to do it do it